Hey everyone! We've made it through ...
production and costs and we understand the ...
marginal-average relationship.
We are now going to make the distinction between the ...
short run and the long run.
Up to this point, you have been producing ...
content on a daily and weekly basis without much thought ...
about how big you want your operation to be.
Perhaps you want to reach millions of subscribers.
But what will that take?
In two words: planning horizon.
You need to know how big of an operation you want and ...
plan for that size. Keep in mind that you ...
produce in the short run and you plan for the long run.
You can scale your operation up or down,
but it will take time.
One thing that is on your side is that no costs are fixed in ...
the long run. Rent?
Don't worry about it, you'll budget it in.
Computers and software? Nope.
Not fixed in the long run because you can scale up or ...
down in the long run. The key is determining how ...
much you want to produce.
Here we have cost and created content increasing.
Let's start with planning for a small operation.
Notice that I you are paying a lot per unit of created content ...
for only creating a little bit of content.
With this level of planning your long run average total ...
costs are going to be high.
If you alter that plan and decide to plan for a bigger ...
operation look what happens.
Now your operation has grown a bit,
and your long run average costs have fallen.
If we scale up production some more we get this
Your long run average costs continue to fall and the ...
amount of content you create continues to increase.
Think of it like this. At the first planned scale ...
your long run average costs were $1,000 per created content
But at this third planned scale,
it's now $700. If we add plan for a large ...
scale we get this.
Now we have reached a minimum efficient scale.
Long run average costs are at their lowest.
Is this the scale you should choose?
Not necessarily. It might not be the most ...
profitable scale. If you continue to scale up ...
your planned production, you'll get the following.
Now, you are producing a lot of ...
content, but your long run average ...
costs are now increasing instead of decreasing.
You planned for too many trips and too much software ...
and workers. It eats into your budget.
And there we have it a long run average cost curve based ...
on the different planned scales you have.
What scale you choose and how long it takes you to get ...
there depends on a variety of factors.
If you're just starting out, a large operation is years away.
But scaling-up is feasible.
Why did that long run average cost curve have a U-shape?
We saw with the short run that increasing and ...
diminishing returns kick in and causes costs to fall and ...
rise. That same type of logic holds here.
As a firm begins to scale up production they can take ...
advantage of economies of scale.
Workers take advantage of the division of labor and ...
specialization and become more efficient at their own tasks.
Firms can purchase resources in a greater volume ...
and get discount pricing.
Or perhaps, workers discover some new ...
technologies that make them more efficient.
As the scale grows it's possible that the firm reaches ...
constant returns to scale.
Here, increasing output does not ...
change the long run average cost for the firm.
Lastly a firm a plan and put into action a firm size that's too big.
Thus achieving diseconomies of scale.
Now the firm has grown too large and problems arise that ...
cause costs to grow as output increases.
Communication is an issue year as managers and ...
executives may have differing goals.
Coordinating all the aspects of the firm becomes difficult.
Regulations may also scale up with the firm.
What size operation you choose is ultimately a ...
long-run strategy in producing today is a short run decision.
Alright! That's it!
We've gone through production and costs.
Hope you enjoyed it.